tonight joe biden will use his primetime
speech to pitch his radical spending
spree
which includes a massive expansion of
american welfare programs
the price tag more than six trillion
dollars
so how does he plan to pay for it magic
for sure
joining joining me now with a preview
is martha mccallum anchor and executive
editor of the story she will be leading
tonight's live coverage
on the fox news channel with bret baer
martha great seeing you
thank you uh for for being here and it's
gonna be a fascinating night it's been a
long time it's a very late addressment
to to congress
uh he has had some accomplishments uh
many people have pointed out myself
included
he's had some failures uh what do you
expect tonight what's going to be
happening
you know tammy thank you first of all
it's great to be with you tonight and we
are looking forward to this address
we've been looking forward to it for
some time
uh generally we see these in february
and i think in keeping with sort of the
tone of the biden campaign and the biden
presidency it's going to be sort of a
quiet affair there's only going to be
about 200 people
in the audience you won't have that sort
of you know bully bully and handshakes
and all of that
at least not to the extent that we're
used to on the way in
and and i expect you know i was
listening to your commentary in the
beginning and i
and i think that um that it's right on
the mark i i think i do expect that
we're going to see sort of a very
quiet measured temper joe biden in the
way he
speaks about where we are as a nation i
was thinking to myself i wonder what it
would be like
if it was president trump tonight i
think he'd be hearing a message
of you know we're open for business
we're cutting taxes we're lowering
regulations we want businesses to be on
fire all that kind of stuff
but i think you're going to hear you
know we're going to protect you we're
going to take care of you we're going to
hold your hand from cradle to grave
essentially because it is about
pre-k and then it's about elder care so
literally
um you know a government sort of embrace
uh
from childhood into into eldercare is
what we're gonna hear a lot about
tonight and and
that has gotten uh president biden a lot
of traction
from his side of the aisle to be sure
now what's interesting too
is you're right the delivery will be um
modulated it'll be a moderate sounding
delivery it's important though that
people
really listen to what he's saying not
just the nature of how he's saying it
because that's how
a president trump was attacked often was
uh
his manner perhaps his delivery uh was
somewhat surprising uh but what really
does matter clearly
is their intentions and the actual
outcomes of policy
right and and this we are going to hear
some of that and it's going to be
though paid for they say it's already
paid for but in fact
it's not been paid for maybe half the
the
analysts are saying they can't figure
out where at least half of it and how it
will be paid for
obviously he's not going to hang on that
and then there's the other issues like
the border
uh will he even address the border like
what could he say about the border since
it's such a mess
do you think he'll avoid certain things
you know in terms of paying tammy i
think we've all it's pretty scary
but we've almost gotten past the whole
notion that anything should be paid for
all of these spending programs go out 15
years you know far beyond
any one person's presidency so it's like
let that person worry about it you know
we'll see we know we're not worried
about how it's going to get paid for at
this point
the other thing i would point out is
that although they've been really
emphasizing from the white house that
it's only going to be the one percent
who pay for this if you make less than
400
000 you're not going to have to pay any
additional taxes in this plan
however when you tax on corporate taxes
when you add in
those kinds of measures what you see is
companies tightening their belts not
expanding
not hiring new employees you see them
them recoiling uh from growing there and
then can we
believe some of these peripheral things
have a big impact on
on everybody's pocket if we can even
believe them because it was the same
confidence with which they said we can
keep our doctor and so
and then it relies on a class war like
oh well we're just going to tax those
people but those are the people who are
creating the businesses and the jobs
that we then rely on to to be consumers
and to live our lives and
and everything else there's only going
to be 200 people in the audience do you
think that's
going to be a factor in the in what the
response is going to be
uh and do you think that that is uh
something that he'll feed off on
and and how long do you think this will
go do you think it'll be past 30 minutes
maybe an hour
you know um we thought that the first
press conference might be short based on
what we had seen over the course of the
campaign and
um i think when he's in this environment
i think he will handle it completely
fine you know i think he'll stand up
there and probably talk for about an
hour like most presidents do
but in terms of the audience you know i
think back to covering
this campaign i remember when we were in
delaware and there were cars lined up
and they were honking
um you know he has had all kinds of
strange covered era
environments to function in and he's
done just fine i think he would be
shocked if
you know if the room were full i think
there would be you know some some panic
uh in some quarters of this
administration that's one other thing i
would make a point on
tammy is that just that in terms of
covet and optimism
you know um it would be great to hear a
message
of you know real optimism about the
future enthusiasm
about how far we've come excitement
about what's around the corner
for the country we've seen you know such
a measured
measure you know i think when the
president came out the other day and
said you know guess what you can take
off your mask in
and be in a small gathering outdoors
with your family
if you're all vaccinated i think a lot
of people across the country just said
well we were you know we were doing that
for quite a while exactly sorry
right i but you're right because we look
to the president
for optimism and this will be the test
to see if he can actually deliver that
in some regard
martha great seeing you thank you have
fun tonight it's going to be very
exciting